John McClane of Houston Chronicle
joining me how are you John I'm driving
again well I think if I'm not mistaken
it you did not signal and got pulled
over years ago is that if I'm correct
right that happened exactly right
all right John okay and and and I just
want to make sure though I when I hear
the clicking and you're in your car
that's you're using your signal to
change lanes okay I hope you're
hands-free all right let's get let's get
to tonight what do you think tonight's
gonna be look like in that Stadium
tonight John very dreary day here right
now weather-wise foggy cold been rainy
it's kind of like he's never in a
seventh game of the World Series and
used it when they want two years ago at
Dodger Stadium right so last night a lot
of fans for best confidence but with
Verlander being so bad in the World
Series and Strasburg being so good in
the World Series and the 2000 I think
that was a false conference it was borne
out by Zack Greinke who hadn't been
feeling well in the playoffs you getting
regular seasons this is why they paid
dearly to get him The X Factor to me is
surgery touches you and stuff that you
ever see and I'll get to you later
people here are really worried about
that surgery
yeah it's it just depends on how his
neck and his back is I I'm not surprised
about that so who do you think needs to
come up with a big game for Houston
tonight give me the name other than
Greinke obviously give me the guy that
you think can carry the day here tonight
John last night he came up with two on
second third one out had a terrible and
bad to talk down bad pitch he's the
leader he's the senior member he needs
to step up and have the kind of gave me
having Sta
that one is John McClane Houston
Chronicle joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show and what would it mean to
have Houston win
second in three years place in
perspective what it means and and how
the the city views this team we all know
how the the nation's been viewing this
the the front office and ownership over
the last few weeks just put it all
together for me John reaches you know
anytime you do something for the first
time it's the most special but when the
Astros this season were favored to win
at all 117 and when they want those two
games here : Berliner it was long and
then they like thought there's no way
they're gonna win this series nobody
want three in a row at Nationals
ballpark people got fired up and so I
think now because they were so down he
thing when it is will be spectacular
especially everybody says well since
they fired top and they will free it out
so it doesn't watch this they just got
beat but they're trying to put that
controversy behind them
apologize ran with traction Jim crane
stepped up they fired the guy but now
they don't want to lose the World Series
on top of all that controversy because
they know a lot of people are pulling
against them because they don't like the
Astros John McClain Houston Chronicle
here on the Rich Eisen show when when do
you head to London John when do you go
there
I'm headed to the airport right now read
ah
okay I appreciate you giving this for
miss calling before you head over there
what what would you say now that the
Texans are about to embark on the second
half of their season what is the story
of the first half of their season John
injuries their offensive line is
secondary deshaun Watson carrying the
team course JJ Watt just went down for
the season that in 2016 in a wanton
vision in a game and nobody's that
replaced individual everything is on
deshaun Watson right now a lot of people
believe rates as long as he's healthy
he's capable of beating anybody anytime
anywhere except maybe the Patriots in
Foxborough Jane works well and you look
you don't need me to say but I will say
anyway to set up this question having
covered the Oilers and Texans over the
last 40 years you know on the NFL that
when something is rumor and something
might actually be happening and calls
are becoming in to a team for a player
and the reason why is because everyone
in the league thinks that the kid might
have fallen out of favor or is available
for some reason why was DeAndre Hopkins
name mentioned as trade bait possibility
yesterday obviously he's still on the
team going to London but why is there
any smoke there John we're not
interested in levy on bells bars DeAndre
Hopkins Kings can call until they're
blue in the face he's not going anywhere
two years left on his contract he leads
the league in first down catch is he
secondly in catches if they were to
trade in shine once and I think we did
leave the city because he means so much
to him I don't know where that got
started Kings work college but nope no
King and there's there's no there there
about Bill O'Brien and Hopkins maybe not
on the same page and
however way shape or form that could be
interpreted well nobody's big on being
keen wire I didn't want me and so he may
not be on the same page with a lot of
players but sometimes those players are
so good you just got to be in the same
book if you're not on the same page and
nobody would be dumb enough to try to
trade me hungry options did you hear
Gruden call Watson Michael Jordan John
hear that he said we got Watson and they
did it Watson had a great game in the
net spectacular play at the end in which
he got kicked in the eye right now his
eye is swollen it was swelled shut
swollen show after the game side the
next day on Monday he was wearing change
the play against Jaguars
that need to take a Londoner he got to
England he took that luxury coach last
year to Jacksonville was that the last
lung broken ribs so it's Watson as you
know which is great no quarterback he
makes me correctly why everything
revolves around him is it true and last
one for him John before I let you head
off the airport obviously everything
with the NBA and China has died down is
daryl morey safe Johnny Daryl Morey and
what was it like to have Chris Paul back
in the house this past week what was
that what was that scene like Johnny you
know there's not ability in our big part
the best ways are than Russell is record
great friends was tremendous game
Rockets pulled it out a lot of people
like Chris Paul here he played hurt
didn't worked out if they'd have been
healthy two years ago a lot of people
think they would
the championship but loyal they moved on
and they've got a colossal and last one
for you John you've seen four decades of
football and we've seen half a season
right here what do you think makes the
Super Bowl as you guess it had me off to
the airport 49ers surprised I'm sticking
with Saints and the Patriots with the
Patriots tour fly safe John I'll see you
over and I'll see you in Wembley I'll be
there you guys John McClane Houston
Chronicle on his way to the airport for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app